this is a tweet from ben and jerry's ice
cream um
i think by the way
keeping ben and jerry's in mind daily
wire might need to start its own ice
cream
company as well so ben and jerry says we
are heartbroken by the loss of our
fellow vermonter fern feather
sadly she was another transgender person
targeted for simply being herself
this was trending over the weekend
because ben and jerry's tweeted it and
other left-wing accounts which were
tweeting it
about this transgender person who was
who was murdered
and the claim being made by ben and
jerry's and everybody else on the left
is that this was this was a hate crime
this was someone who was killed for
being transgender but yet
you read the article
that ben jerry's linked to you actually
click on it and read it this is what you
see
a few paragraphs down
uh you get to this
well first at the beginning it says the
killing of a transgender woman in
morristown drew outrage and condemnation
across vermont on wednesday hinesburg
resident fern feather 29 was found
stabbed to death along a morristown road
on tuesday morning according to vermont
state police
feather's death prompted an outpouring
of grief and anger from top state
officials and on social media house
speaker representative jill krawinski
said feather was tragically taken from
this world too soon like so many other
transgender people who are targeted
in bias-driven attacks
krawinski said we absolutely need to
continue to take steps to make vermont a
more equitable place and be clear that
hate has no place
in our states
well yeah we know uh that
bigoted right-wing
cesspool of vermont
so this is the direct claim that they're
making that this person fern feather was
killed for being transgender
yet you read a few more paragraphs down
this is what it says
prosecutors have charged seth brunell 43
with second-degree murder in feather's
death brunel who
was not known to have a fixed address
have been spending time with feather
before the killing
roughly two hours before feather's body
was found
officers with the sheriff's department
had encountered the pair in a car
together in the parking lot
um
deputies checked on feather and burnell
and waited for them to leave the parking
lot upon his arrest burnell told police
they had been defending himself against
feather who made a sexual advance and
attacked him
investigators observed no injuries or
evidence of a struggle or an assault on
brunel
now the point is i have no idea whether
this self-defense claim is true or not
whether he's telling the truth i don't
know
but there is nothing in that description
of the crime
that indicates at all that this was a
hate crime
there is right now
zero evidence none that this person was
killed for being transgender
just that they were killed that they
were a transgender person who now uh
sadly is dead
and the way that the left does this now
is it is that the simple fact that a
transgender person was killed is itself
evidence of a hate crime
and that's why you can read articles
like on um
when i just had pulled out from pbs
this was at the end of last year
and it said with nearly two months left
2021 has shattered the record of
transgender homicides in a year with 45
to date according to the human rights
campaign
last year held the record with 44 trans
murders
and this was there were a lot of
headlines towards the end of last year
but i was the deadliest
uh year quote unquote the deadliest year
on record for transgender people and and
and these are all hate crimes
except that's just that's the number of
transgender people who are murdered
period across in the across the entire
country for an entire year 45.
and the claim is
what that with without without hate
crimes
no transgender person would ever be
murdered
like there's there's no other reason why
a trans person would ever be killed
so you we get rid of the hate crime
problem and no trans people are would be
immune from murder
of course that doesn't make any sense at
all
given that murder is uh something that
happens in uh sadly in every community
in america
you take any group of people any
demographic
and in a given year a certain portion of
them are going to be murdered
just because they're human beings living
in a society where this sort of thing
happens
that is not itself evidence of a hate
crime
now if you were to whittle that down you
take that 45 number and you look at it
and you look at each individual case how
many of them
out of the 45
how many of them were proven to be
actual hate crimes as in the person was
killed for being transgender and what
you find is that it's a vanishingly
small number
vast majority of people murdered for who
are transgender it's domestic disputes
drug related prostitution related in
other words it's the same reason why
most murders occur
against most demographics of people
those are the facts not that it matters
at all of course to the left hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated